[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend und sportliches hast du
später wieder BCK Chris tolles vom
Wintersport guten Abend unsere Themen im
Überblick die mit einem pikanten Besuch
beginnen
umstittener Gast in Berlin
Bundespräsident Steinmeier und Kanzler
Scholz empfangen den türkischen
Präsidenten
Erdogan Elterngeld Mehrwertsteuer Barfög
die Ampel feilt weiter am Haushalt aber
nach dem Richterspruch vom Mittwoch
steht alles unter
Vorbehalt US Pharmariese investiert
Milliarden in Rheinland pfals das
Bundesland ist auf dem Weg zu einem
führenden Standort für
Biotechnologie der türkische Präsident
Erdogan wird in wenigen Minuten mit dem
Kanzler zu Abend Essen zuvor gab es eine
denkwürdige Pressekonferenz es ist der
umstrittenste Besuch seit langem weil
Erdogan Israel als Terrorstaat und die
Hamas als freiheitsorganisation
bezeichnet der Kanzler hat das zwar
schon absurd als absurd zurückgewiesen
denn noch erwarten viele noch mal eine
klare Distanzierung aber es ist ein
diplomatischer Ritt auf der Rasierklinge
weil Berlin Ankara auch als
strategischen Partner braucht Britta
Spiekermann
die Stimmung sichtlich angespannt kein
Lächeln Bundespräsident Steinmeier
empfängt den umstrittenen Gast Erdogan
protokolarische
Mindeststandards es wird nicht besser
beim Eintrag ins Goldene Buch Erdogan
unterschreibt mehr nicht kein Blick
keine Geste
Tiefpunkt zu heftig die verbal Attacken
des türkischen Präsidenten im Vorfeld im
Parlament in Ankara israel sei ein
Terrorstaat dieamas eine befreiungs
Entsetzen in Deutschland heute der
Versuch des Dialogs in politischer
Großwetterlage trotz aller Differenzen
roter Teppich für den Autokraten ein
Lächeln dann doch Scholz vermittelnd und
bestimmt das Existenzrecht Israels ist
für uns
unumstößlich und lassen Sie mich genauso
klar sagen in unserem Land ist kein
Platz für
Antisemitismus versuchen wir gemeinsam
dieitre waffenuh zu gewrleisten dann
können wir dieses Gebiet aus diesem
Feuer
retten die Türkei strategisch wichtiges
natomitglied mit immer noch engem
Kontakt zu Putin Schlüsselrolle auch bei
der Migration das eutürkeiabkommen von
2016 soll wiederbelebt werden
deutschland braucht die Türkei die
wirtschaftlich angeschlagene Türkei
Deutschland mein Gefühl ist die deutsche
Regierung opfert ihre Werte für
Interessen und Erdogan bestimmt die
Regeln erdogan ist setting the rules
erdoan ein unbequemer ungeliebter Gast
abendessengespräche dann heute schon
Abreise es geht nur sehr schwer mit ihm
aber ohne ihn geht es wohl auch nicht
wir sprechen mit Diana Zimmermann in
Berlin die die Pressekonferenz zwischen
Scholz und Erdogan bis vor wenigen
Minuten live verfolgt hat Diana wie
haben sich die beiden
positioniert ja die beiden haben ganz
klar ihre plföcker eingeschlagen die am
entgegengesetzten Ende der Diskussion um
nah Ost stehen Kanzler Scholz hat von
Anfang an sehr klar gemacht dass für ihn
der Beginn der Aggressionen am 7 Oktober
liegt beim Angriff der Hamas auf die
israelische Zivilbevölkerung und klar
gemacht dass das was momentan in Gaza
passiert ein das Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung Israels betrifft
der türkische Präsident hat
ausschließlich von den palästinensischen
Opfern gesprochen er selbst stellt sich
als den kühlen Kopf da in der
aufgeheizten Situation in narost einen
einen Vorteil sozusagen den er glaubt
gegenüber den Deutschen zu haben er hat
ziemlich klar gesagt dass Deutschland
aufgrund des Holocaust nicht in der Lage
sei hier objektiv zu
urteilen Tatsache ist auch das wissen
wir dass die Türkei gerne 40 € fighter
jets kaufen würde dafür bräuchte man
eigentlich die Zustimmung Deutschlands
und gegen Ende der Pressekonferenz hat
sich ein sehr drohender Ton in die Rede
von Erdogan eingeschlichen ind dem er
sagte man könne Flugzeuge auch woanders
kaufen das schien ein bisschen ohne
Anlass die beiden haben also denkbar
schlechte Vorzeichen für die Gespräche
die jetzt erst beginnen immerhin konnten
sie sich beide darauf einigen dass sie
eine Eskalation dieses Konfliktes in der
OST verhindern wollen danke für deine
Einschätzung Diana live aus
Berlin nach dem Urteil der Bundes des
Verfassungsrichter vom Mittwoch Fehlen
der Bundesregierung ja 60 Milliarden
Euro und so war nicht unbedingt zu
erwarten dass der Haushaltsausschuss
schon so viele Beschlüsse für geplante
Neuausgaben auf den Tisch legt aber
überraschenderweise gab es genau die
nach nächtlicher Marathonsitzung etwa
die Verlängerung der energiepreisbremse
und statt Streichungen doch mehr Geld
für Freiwilligendienste und was noch
geplant ist dazu Alexandra
wacano ob Schnitzel Pasta oder Salat es
könnte teurer werden die 7%
Mehrwertsteuer in der Gastronomie aus
und vorbei die in der Pandemie
runtergesetzte Steuer geht jetzt wieder
rauf auf 19% ab dem
1.1 beim Elterngeld fallen die Kürzungen
weniger hart aus zwar sinkt die
Einkommensgrenze aber nach viel Kritik
nur schrittweise von 300.000 € für Paare
auf zunächst 200.000 € ab April ein Jahr
später auf 175
€ studierende können auf mehr
Unterstützung hoffen beim barfck im
kommenden Jahr auf die veranschlagten
1,92 Milliarden Euro legen die
Haushälter noch 150 Millionen Euro oben
drauf einen Milliarden Nachschlag gibt
es für das Bürgergeld mit 4,8 Milliarden
Euro denn das steigt ab Januar für mehr
als 5 Millionen Erwachsene und Kinder in
der
Grundsicherung und überraschend der groß
Geldtopf für die long covidforschung 100
Millionen Euro für Erwachsene und 50
Millionen für Kinder weil über die
Krankheit noch zu wenig bekannt
ist ja die Opposition die hält den
gesamten Haushalt 2024 für unseriös und
schäumt die Union erwckt deshalb
möglicherweise auch eine Klage gegen
einen anderen Fond der Ampel mit dem die
Strom- und gaspreisbremse finanziert
werden eine Androhung die den Druck auf
die Bundes Regierung weiter steigen
lässt mehr von Ines
Trams bis morgens 4:30 Uhr rangen die
Haushaltspolitiker um den ETA fürs
nächste Jahr doch alles steht unter
Vorbehalt nach dem Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts große Posten wurden
ausgespart endgültige Sitzung erst
nächsten Donnerstag die ganzen heißen
Eisen haben wir eigentlich gestern Nacht
nicht zu Ende gebracht und das wird
alles jetzt im Nachsitzen kommen einig
ist die Ampel dass in der Gastronomie ab
nächstem Jahr wieder der volle
Mehrwertsteuersatz von 19% gelten soll
ein Beispiel für Einsparungen doch trotz
riesiger Finanzierungslücken will die
Ampel auch geplante Einschnitte
zurücknehmen wir werden auch weiter die
psychosozialen Zentren zur Betreuung von
geflüchteten unterstützen wir werden
Jugendmigrationsdienste weiter
unterstützen und wir haben auch noch mal
ein Schwerpunkt gesetzt bei der ganzen
Frage Bekämpfung von Antisemitismus und
jüdischen und Unterstützung jüdischen
Lebens angesichts der unklaren Situation
und drohender großer Finanzlöcher
kritisiert die Union die Mehrausgaben
der Ampel und stellt eigene Berechnungen
an dann hat die Ampel gestern noch mal
ein ordentlichen Schluck aus der Pulle
genommen wir haben zusammengerechnet
dass wir ungefähr 32,5 Milliarden mehr
Ausgaben oder die Ampel gestern 32,5
Milliarden mehr Ausgaben beschlossen hat
ich frage mich ernsthaft wie wollen die
die am Ende denn finanzieren die Union
erwegt derzeit eine weitere Klage sie
lässt nun auch den WSF den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond rechtlich
überprüfen er finanziert die
energiepreisbremsen auch die Ampel ist
hier unsicher die Frage was wir jetzt
aus dem WSF noch machen könnten die
prüfen wir ja gerade noch wie viel im
WSF überhaupt noch beweglich ist nach
dem Urteil für Dienstag ist auf Wunsch
der Union eine Expertenanhörung
angesetzt sie soll Klarheit bringen wie
konkret der Haushalt dem Urteil aus
karlsrohe angepasst werden
muss egal was sich tut immer informiert
bleiben sie auf ZDF heute und jetzt auch
unter Aktuelles bei Whatsapp entweder
den angezeigten QR-Code scannen oder sie
abonnieren uns direkt bei Whatsapp
selbst alles was wichtig ist kurz und
kompakt mit Updates jeweils morgens und
abends es scheint sich tatsächlich
anzubahnen dass der israelische
Militäreinsatz auf den Süden des
gazerstreifens ausgedehnt wird
Regierungschef netanahu drückte in einem
Interview sein Bedauern über die vielen
zivilen Opfer aus diese Tatsache und die
Angehörigen der noch vermissten Geiseln
erhöhen den Druck auf netanahu Henriette
demia
berichtet seit vier Tagen nun sind sie
unterwegs die Angehörigen der Geiseln
rund 70 km laufen sie von telaviv nach
Jerusalem alle Menschen Israels
unterstützen uns alle hier um uns herum
alle unterstützen die Befreiung der
Geiseln ich lauf hier mit um die
Familien zu unterstützen und es ist das
wenigste was man machen kann wir hoffen
alle dass sie bald zurückkommen die
ganzen
entführten währenddessen kämpft die
israelische Armee im Gazastreifen weiter
liefert Bilder von waffenfunden aus dem
inzwischen besetzten alschifer
Krankenhaus es brauche eine politische
Lösung um die Spirale der Gewalt zu
durchbrechen betont der euen tragte
heute in
ramala die Europäische Union hat
nachdrücklich betont dass es darauf
ankommt wie Israel sein Recht auf
Verteidigung wahrnimmt dass Israel das
humanitäre Völkerrecht und den Grundsatz
der Verhältnismäßigkeit respektieren
muss die Luftangriffe der israelischen
Armee gingen im nördlichen Teil des
Gazastreifens unvermindert weiter zivile
Opfer in Kauf nehmt wie der israelische
Minister Präsident im US-Fernsehen
einräumte wir versuchen den Job so zu
erledigen dass es möglichst wenige
zivile Opfer gibt aber wir sind dabei
leider nicht
erfolgreich morgen werden die
Angehörigen der Geiseln in Jerusalem
erwartet sie ziehen zum Regierungssitz
fordern dort die sofortige Freilassung
aller
Geiseln jetzt nach telaviv zu Michael
beberunge Michael es gibt Hinweise auf
eine Ausweitung der Operation in südgasa
gleichzeitig hält die Hamas ja immer
noch über 200 Geiseln fest wie hängt
beides
zusammen also die Anzeichen einer
Ausweitung der israelischen
Bodenoffensive auf den Süden von Gaza
die verdichten sich die he sagt die
hamassa im Norden von Gaza weitgehend
zerschlagen Verteidigungsminister
Galland hat angekündigt dass die
Operation am Boden nun in ihre zweite
Phase treten würde und im Süden von Gaza
werden seit Tagen Flugblätter abgeworfen
die die Bevölkerung auffordern den
südöstlichen Teil von Gaza zu verlassen
direkt an der Grenze zu Israel dem
entgegen steht aber die Freilassung der
Geisel ein konkreter Deal steht seit
Tagen im Raum Premierminister Netanyahu
hat sogar gesagt er wäre zu einer
temporären Waffenpause bereit wenn es
die Freilassung von Geisen ermöglichen
würde aber der steht im Moment nicht an
dieser Deal und deswegen wird im
Kabinett darüber diskutiert soll man
noch länger zuwarten um einen solchen de
Raum zu geben oder soll man das Momentum
der bisherigen Offensive nutzen um eben
in den Süden vorzustoßen die
Entscheidung darüber steht in der
Schwebe aber ich denke es klar dass es
ist klar dass die Ausweitung der
Bodenoffensive auf den Süden nicht mehr
allzu lange ausstehen dürfte vielen Dank
für deine Einschätzung nach Tel Aviv
Michael auch der russische Angriffskrieg
in der Ukraine bringt jeden Tag Tod und
Leid rund 9800 ukrainische Zivilisten
wurden bis jetzt getötet so die
Vereinten Nationen aber belastbare
Zahlen zu gefallenen Soldaten gibt es
nicht unzählige Opfer sind begraben ohne
dass man weiß wer sie sind Forensiker
versuchen Ihnen die Identität
wiederzugeben eine schwere aber sehr
wichtige Arbeit denn so bekommen
Angehörige Gewissheit und können
Abschied nehmen Dara Hassan
sad Monate suchte nach ihrem Ehemann er
war im Kampf verschollen erst der DNA
Abgleich mit der Tochter führte zum
nummerngrab des Vaters nur 40 km
entfernt ist er
gefallen als ich dort am Massengrab
ankam ich fand mich nicht
zurecht ich wusste nicht wohin wo ich
nachschauen soll es waren so viele von
ihnen über00 namenlose Leichname muss
dieer Polizei noch identifizieren viele
Soldaten aber auch zivile Opfer von
russischen Luftangriffen oft bis zur
Unkenntlichkeit
entstellt wenn wir den Zustand vieler
Leichen nach einem Luftangriff in
Betracht ziehen das ist nur
furchtbar vor Ort nehmen wir von jedem
Körperteil eine DNA Probe um den
Leichnam möglichst wieder zu
vereinen allein ein Luftangriff im
letzten Monat mit 59 Toten erforderte
mehr als 3000 DNA
weil in manchen Fällen dutzende
Körperteile zusammengeführt werden
mussten das wäre ohne moderne DN Technik
aus den USA
unmöglich bei der Arbeit versuchen wir
vor allem daran zu denken dass wir den
Angehörigen mit unseren Analysen helfen
wir helfen indem wir die Identitäten von
vermissten klären das Ende der
Ungewissheit am Grab ihres Mannes mit
ihrer Tochter zu trauern sagtxana nur so
könne sie irgendwann Frieden finden
jetzt eine Meldung aus der Wirtschaft
die aufhorchen lässt der
US-amerikanische farmerriiese Eli Lilli
will in Deutschland expandieren im
Rheinland ffelsischen alssei plant der
Konzern ein neues Werk und das im
Gegensatz zu anderen Unternehmen ganz
ohne deutsche Steuergelder Eli Lilli
produziert unter anderem ein
Diabetesmittel das in den USA auch als
abnehmspritze zugelassen ist mittel
gegenübergewicht erleben derzeit ja
einen wahren Boom ans Stern
berichtet im Kleinen allzeai in
Rheinlandpfalz soll schon bald groß
gebaut werden der usfarmer Riese Eli
Lilli investiert hier insgesamt 2,3
Milliarden Euro es gehe um ein neues
hightechwerk bis zu 1000 Arbeitsplätze
vor allem für Ingenieure und Forscher
sollen bis 2027 entstehen die
Entscheidung für Deutschland und
insbesondere für alszei ist insbesondere
gefallen aufgrund der hervorragenden
Infrastruktur die wir hier vorgefunden
haben und der sehr gut ausgebildeten
Fachkräfte aufgleich zwei
Pressekonferenzen werden die mal guten
Nachrichten für den Standort Deutschland
verkündet in allzei und in Berlin gleich
zwei Bundesminister sind dabei die sich
besonders freuen über die Tatsache dass
elai Lilli keine Subventionen bekommt
also ohne deutsches Steuergeld in
Deutschland investiert das sind also
wirklich wirtschaftliche Entscheidung
die nicht angelogt worden durch Geld
sondern durch die Stärken des Standorts
Deutschland hat einen sehr guten
pharmastandort die Abgesänge auf
Deutschland in diesem Bereich sind
einfach nicht richtig wir haben eine
starke pharmazeutische Industrie und wir
profitieren von zusätzlichen
Investitionen Eli Lilli der wertvollste
börsennotierte Gesundheitskonzern der
Welt will künftig vor allem Sein
diabetesmedikament in Deutschland
produzieren das ist in den USA auch als
sogenannte abnehmspritze zugelassen für
die durchaus sehr umstrittene und te ure
schnelle Fettwegspritze will der
US-Konzern jetzt auch eine Zulassung in
Europa bekommen der farmiese hofft damit
auf neue gewaltige
Gewinne Deutschland Türkei heute findet
das politisch statt und morgen Christine
dann sportlich besondere Partie an ein
besonderen Ort 70.000 im Berliner
Olympiastadion ausverkauft eine Kulisse
wie sie auch beim Finale der heimem
erwartet wird ein Sieg gegen die
türkischen Gäste könnte also genau der
richtige motivationst sein in der
Hauptstadt die Mannschaft ist am
Nachmittag in Berlin angekommen vor dem
türkeispiel gilt am Teamhotel eine
erhöhte Sicherheitsstufe beim em
Härtetest muss die deutsche Auswahl
überraschend ohne Mark andritas deeggen
auskommen der wegen Rückenproblemen
ausfällt das heimdebü von Julian
nagelsmann im ausverkauften
Olympiastadion wird auch zu einem
Stimmungstest
Emotion gehören dazu und es geh eine
gewisse Lautstärke dazu da freuen wir
uns auch Drau die darf aus beiden
Fanlagern kommen das ist morgen laut
wird sowohl die türkischen als auch die
deutschen Fans sollen richtig laut
schreien und Alarm machen aber alles
alles fair und alles friedlich wer gegen
die Türkei im Tor steht lie nagelsmann
noch offen Kevin Trapp hat die besten
Einsatzchancen mit einem Doppelerfolg
für die deutschen begann in China die
neue Wintersaison im Skeleton bei den
Frauen war Tina Hermann die schnellste
ihr Teamkollege und Olympiasieger
Christopher grot dominierte im
olympischen Eiskanal von 2022 die
Männerkonkurrenz vor dem Chinesen
chen und an selber Stelle ebenfalls
überzeugend der Weltcup Einstieg für die
deutschen Bobfahrer Weltmeister Johannes
Lochner raste im Zweier mit Anschieber
Georg fleischauer zur Bestzeit platz 2
ging an Francesco Friedrich und
Alexander Schüller son übergreifend ist
es lochners Sieb Sieg
nacheinander und noch zum Tennis keine
Chance mehr aufs Halbfinale für
Alexander s bei den ATP Finals in Turin
denn Carlos alkaras aus Spanien hat sich
durch den zweisatzerfolg gegen den
Russen Daniel medwiedev den letzten
Platz in der Vorschlussrunde gesichert
und sweres Traum vom dritten Triumph
beim Saisonabschluss beendet also ist
sein letztes Match heute Abend ohne
Bedeutung so kann es gehen danke schön
Christin ja gerade mal 8 Jahre alt und
schon vorgeladen bei der Polizei muss
nichts Schlimmes bedeuten zumindest
heute am bundesweiten Vorlesetag an dem
machen ja traditionell möglichst viele
Erwachsene möglichst vielen Kindern das
Lesens schmackhaft und die 2b der
Mainzer leibnitschule durfte dafür ins
Polizeipräsidium es Laren Beamtin Reck
und Beamtin Magdeburg oh ja
natürlich
klein ja so wie sich für ihre Kreise
gehört len sie aus einem kinderkrimie
sehr schön so das Wetter das gibt's
gleich mit
christben das heute journal wie immer am
Freitag um 22 Uhr heute mit Christian
Siebers das war's von uns morgen an
dieser Stelle Barbara hallweg danke fürs
zuschauen Ihnen einen schönen Start ins
[Musik]
Wochenende guten Abend Frostschutz den
brauchen viele anfällige Pflanzen heute
Nacht denn dieses Zwischenhoch sorgt in
Kombination mit dem abziehenden tief für
etwas mehr Kälte in unserem Wetter
morgen Nachmittag ist das aber schon
wieder vorbei da erreicht uns eine
Warmfront mit Regen und wieder sehr
milder Luft aber noch nicht heute Nacht
da sinken die Werte auf 4 bis 0°
zwischen der Nordsee und dem Bayerischen
Wald und an den Alpen ist dann der Frost
möglich bis -3° und dazu kann es
ördentlich glatt werden denn es bildet
sich teils dich der Nebel und im Süden
anfangs auch im Südwesten regnet es noch
oberhalb von 700 m fällt Schnee die
vereinzelten Schauer im Osten des Landes
lassen morgen Vormittag dann rasch nach
und auch in den östlichen Alpen wird es
trocken und trocken bei wechselnd der
bwölkung startet der Tag nachmittags
kommt dann der kräftige Regen aus Westen
ins Land bei einem starkbüigen auf Süd
drehenden Wind unter den Regenwolken
liegen die Temperaturen schon bei 7 bis
10° im Bergland und im Osten noch bei 4
bis 7° es wird deutlich milder am
Sonntag aus Südwesten mit bis 15° dann
Schauerwetter vereinzelte Gewitter im
Osten noch der kräftigere Regen bei nur
8°
am Montag und am Dienstag viel Regen und
trüb und am Mittwoch wird's richtig kühl
bei nur noch 0 bis 7° tschüss